Another method for adding integers
involves using absolute value.
As long as all the numbers we're
adding have the same sign,
that is they're all positive or all
negative, we can just add the absolute
value of the numbers together and then
use the original sign of the numbers.
For example, if we are adding
positive 3 and positive 2, both 3 and
2 have the same sign.
The absolute value of 3 is 3,
and the absolute value of 2 is 2.
So we can add the absolute value of 3
plus the absolute value of 2 to get 5.
And then use the original
sign that 3 and
2 both shared, which is positive,
and we get positive 5.
Here's where things get interesting.
In the case where we're adding
negative 3 and negative 2, we can take
advantage of the fact that negative
3 and negative 2 share the same sign.
They're both negative.
We can take the absolute
value of each number and
then add those absolute values.
So, what is the absolute value of
negative 3, and what about negative 2.
And what is the absolute
value of negative 3 plus
the absolute value of negative 2.
Enter your answers in the boxes.